all right so once you're all done maybe
if you have uh some good experience
tetris skills you're able to fit
everything in there and get the top back
on
uh as you can see um this was basically
this is mine uh i was able to fit the
top back on there's not much else in
there can't i don't know how you'd fit
the little uh distance sensor but
somehow you could probably do it anyway
when you're all done uh should look
something similar to this
you've probably already found out that
it doesn't work very well on carpet the
motors are just pretty weak so you get
what you pay for uh the motor's like
five dollar motors so
uh i'm driving here on just some
laminate in my kitchen so that's pretty
much the only place i have flat uh flat
flooring the rest is carpet but anyway
once you're done you should be able to
just remote desktop in run your script
and
now you can remote control your car
uh even now
it you know it'll turn okay
still not the best turning uh
but it does okay i suppose uh then pivot
we did code that it's
okay again with pivot it's not really
the best like i can't i can't pivot the
other way right now
just because the motors are just so
pathetic
but anyway uh at least the code works uh
it's just we need more we need more uh
budget and r d so we can actually afford
better stuff
but anyway
uh
that's it uh hopefully you guys enjoyed
i know a lot of people uh put pretty bad
ratings on this i was looking at the
ratings for this little kit online and
most people were complaining about
um there's no con like instructions
given really for for the kit so it's
kind of hard putting it together but i
learned a lot hopefully you guys learned
a lot uh i think it was a good first kit
obviously there's not much else to it
you certainly can't do much with it
because the motors are so weak
but
it was still a lot of fun and i
appreciate the frame i mean you could
just switch out the motors and put some
better motors in there uh
and have a lot more fun with it probably
um but anyways i enjoyed it hopefully
you guys did too uh as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions also if you have any
questions feel free to leave them below
and until next time